it's a journey that still haunts him why
did the others die she could do wonders
and why did he survive on board were
friends and neighbors from barra all
hoping to make it to Europe he says they
had meticulously planned the trip for
weeks but the ocean often brings the
unexpected running out of fuel in food
they had decided to turn around for
supplies when a wave hit them people
panicked the boat capsized off the coast
of Mauritania [ __ ] friends died while he
swam to shore I pray that they have
forgiven me and I hope that I can one
day complete their journey so that we
can all find some peace among the dead
Sofia to a 16 year old orphan Tita Gomez
died with her six-year-old son in her
arms and Jojo Bujang these were young
Gambians fleeing not war but the poverty
in their country
Georgia worked as a waitress in a bar
catering to tourists from Gambia Europe
seems so close at home she would ask her
aunt why it's so easy for Europeans to
come to Africa and so hard for Africans
to go to Europe don't you know for a
better life and to help his parents and
the family that's all he went to the sea
she paid $700 to travel from Barra
to the Canary Islands by boat while the
trafficker who arranged this trip is in
hiding there is no shortage of boatman
willing to make the journey
these are boats made for fishing not to
transport people through the Atlantic
Ocean to the shores of Europe and yet
migrants pack in these vessels sleeping
here eating here sometimes they get lost
on the way so the journey can go from a
few weeks to months on despite the risk
people continue to use this way to get
to Europe because so many have
successfully made it across while jiufen
JoJo's boat sank migrants on three other
vessels traveling with them made it to
the Canary Islands undetected by border
guards they send back pictures of
themselves from shopping malls or
standing next to expensive cars but they
don't show the hardship of life in
Europe
haunted by those who died despite the
failed attempt
Diouf is preparing to travel again it
appears his journey is not over
Nicholas Hawke al Jazeera bara Gambia